python a high-level interpreted
programming language famous for its
zen-like code it's arguably the most
popular language in the world because
it's easy to learn yet practical for
serious projects in fact you're watching
this youtube video in a python web
application right now it was created by
guido van rossum and released in 1991
who named it after monty python's flying
circus which is why you'll sometimes
find spam and eggs instead of foo and
bar in code samples it's commonly used
to build server-side applications like
web apps with the django framework and
is the language of choice for big data
analysis and machine learning many
students choose python to start learning
to code because of its emphasis on
readability as outlined by the zen of
python beautiful is better than ugly
while explicit is better than implicit
python is very simple but avoids the
temptation to sprinkle in magic that
causes ambiguity its code is often
organized into notebooks where
individual cells can be executed then
documented in the same place we're
currently at version 3 of the language
and you can get started by creating a
file that ends in py or ipymb to create
an interactive notebook create a
variable by setting a name equal to a
value it's strongly typed which means
values won't change in unexpected ways
but dynamic so type annotations are not
required the syntax is highly efficient
allowing you to declare multiple
variables on a single line and define
tuples lists and dictionaries with a
literal syntax semicolons are not
required and if you use them and
experience pythonista will say that your
code is not pythonic instead of
semicolons python uses indentation to
terminate or determine the scope of a
line of code define a function with the
def keyword then indent the next line
usually by four spaces to define the
function body we might then add a for
loop to it and indent that by another
four spaces this eliminates the need for
curly braces and semicolons found in
many other languages python is a
multi-paradigm language we can apply
functional programming patterns with
things like anonymous functions using
lambda it also uses objects as an
abstraction for data allowing you to
implement object-oriented patterns with
things like classes and inheritance it
also has a huge ecosystem of third-party
libraries such as deep learning
frameworks like tensorflow and wrappers
for many high performance low level
packages like open computer vision which
are most often installed with the pip
package manager this has been the python
programming language in 100 seconds hit
the like button if you want to see more
short videos like this thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one